In yesterdays video we made a simple homemade contraption
That will convert plastic 2 liter bottles into hundreds of feet of plastic string.
making over 1,200 feet of this plastic
string so for this video I thought it'd
be fun to bring back our rope making
machine and wind these strands together
to see if we could make ourselves a
genuine plastic grip now the two main
questions I saw in my rope making video
were how do you make a longer rope and
what would happen if you were to take
three fully made ropes and wind them
together on the road making machine well
you're in luck because today we're going
to answer both of those questions at the
same time we experiment with our plastic
string now in my original rope making
tutorial I took these two devices and
clamp them to either end of my workbench
and strung a line between them so if you
want to make your rope longer all you
have to do is increase the distance
between them so for today's wrote making
experiment why don't we take our spinner
hook unit and clamp it right here to the
head of my workbench it will take the
back end unit and clamp it across the
room to counter 20 feet away now since
we've increased the distance of a rope
machine we're also going to need to
increase the distance of our guidelines
as well so I went down to the home depot
and picked up a couple packs of 50 foot
paracord this just gives us the option
to run our machine out 50 feet long if
we ever feel like doing that let's go
ahead and bust out some chords and line
our machine
(Music plays)
beautiful thing when a plan comes
together
Here we go
okay the good news guys in a couple of
minutes we've got our rope machine all
set up the guide wires are nice and
tight and the slider moves easily
between both ends so just for fun i went
ahead and measured out the distance
between these two contraptions and it
runs about 22 feet and since the two
liter bottle makes about 95 feet of rope
we're going to need about one and a half
bottles to make this length of rope here
and you know how it works from here
we're going to take our strings thread
it between all the hooks then take a
power drill and wind them all together
most took these suckers up to get
spinning I think I'm going to start out
with green just because that's kind of
unique
all right there's one and a half hooks
done and I don't think we're going to
make it back with this and we shouldn't
need nearly as much just half
cool we got all of our lines strung and
as anticipated it took one and a half
soda bottles to string this line really
curious to see how this works out now
it's looking really good so it's time to
hook up our drill get spinning and see
exactly what happened
(Music plays)
oh wow it's going started making the
rope that's good news we might actually
have some success
(Music plays)
sweet look at that we actually did it we
made a genuine piece of soda bottle rope
now because it's so long I did have to
guide the spacer forward with my hand at
times to release some of the tension
because I felt like the rope was going
to break but once it got within about
four feet is just one on that so no
problem there you have a guy's there is
our length of soda bottle cordage now we
start off with about twenty two and a
half feet of cord and after it while I'm
attention into it this rope turned out
being 18 and a half feet so looks like
it shrunk in size by about 4 feet if you
look really closely you can see it does
actually resemble a three stranded rope
now because the fibers were a little bit
wider than feistel or any other kind of
fiber it gives it a little bit more of a
rough appearance a rough texture it
looks pretty cool nice shiny and green
kind of pretty this actually worked out
pretty well I'm very encouraged let's
rig up our machine and make two more
(Music plays)
beautiful there it is boys two down one to go
Ok im releaseing tention
(Music plays)
update guys we have finished three
different strands of three stranded rope
and they're looking pretty good so what
would happen if you rigged these three
lines up to our machine wound them again
is it possible to wind a three strand
rope out of three strand rope this is rope
reception
(Music plays)
guys I'm excited this is the moment of
truth we have our three strands hooked
up to our rope making machine to make
another rope and it's time to pull the
trigger but there is an important thing
we need to keep in mind whenever we're
making a rope out of three strand of
rope we need to spin the hook the
opposite direction if we spin the ropes
the same way we did when we originally
created them they'll actually undo
themselves this time we need to flip our
drill into reverse and spin hooks the
opposite way you can see it when we spin
the hooks this direction it actually
tightens the rope it makes it harder
which is exactly what we want we don't
want it to undo itself we want it to get
better will it work we're about to find
out here we go
(Music plays)
cool it's not perfect but that is
looking more like a rope so check that
out guys we took three of our robes put
them together and made them into another
rope and this stuff is looking pretty
legit it's a little rough but it looks a
lot more like a rope panels like a rope
and looks incredibly strong now just to
go one step further why don't we take
this stuff cut it into thirds and run
one more cable three times a stick
(Music plays)
that's kind of cool huh all right let's
tape it off and call it good
(Music plays)
success we have done it guys we've
made a beautiful three stranded rope out
of three strands rope out of three
stranded rope the total thickness of our
rope now is nearly half an inch is
extremely strong extremely durable and
surprisingly it actually looks like a
rope I'm not sure how practical it is to
make robot of plastic bottles we can
definitely see it's possible so let's
recap what we've done here today we
start off with small strands of plastic
soda bottle strings so we made some a
homemade contraption using nothing but a
piece of wood and undoing we hope those
strings up to a home made of rope making
machine and weld them together to make
three different three stranded rope
which are very cool by themselves but if
that wasn't enough we took that rope and
cut it into thirds and made one final
rope a rope was in a rope within a rope
rope ception so very very cool to see
that this idea works guide we took
plastic bottles turn them into the
string and use the string to make PE tu
rope this is very very sick very very
durable and can most likely lift
hundreds and hundreds of pounds thanks
for joining for this project today I'll
be looking for you the next one talk to
you then and you can take this and braid
it again and make another rope olb super
strong it's a Christmas wreath hit hit a
plastic bottle kind of hurts the hands a
little bit hey guys thanks for watching
and remember i'm giving away prizes now
on every new video all you have to do to
qualify is subscribe to my channel ring
the bell and select to be notified when
my next videos get released the secret
link to my giveaways will be pinned in
the comments for the first 12 hour if
you like what I'm doing so your support
right now by giving this video a big
thumbs up and share with a friend I love
you back I'll see you next time